Here are this week's Top Movies
- At the circle we can finally realize our potential.
A young woman becomes embroiled in a tech company's privacy invading experiments in "The Circle".
- Does this really seem okay to you?
*I'm watching you*
- I knew how to work it better than anyone
In "How to be a Latin Lover" an ageing lothario learns the real meaning of family.
- I don't know how to undress a woman with my eyes.
- This guy right?
- What's your name?
- Holly.
- You can grab it, Holly.
A street magician uses every trick up his sleeve to find his kidnapped sister in "Sleight".
- These barriers only exist if you let them.
See what's hot in theaters with this week's anticipation.
[music]
So, what's your weekend to get going to be?
Let us know by commenting
See you next time on weekend ticket
[music]